[Music]
gotcha so you're the funny little man
who's been following me funny little man
how dare you I will have you know that I
am a perfectly respectable size for an
OA Lumpa Ina what now in fact in Lumpa
land I am regarded as something of a
Whopper they call me lofty
sorry ladies and gentlemen greetings to
you all my name is Willie won you see
I'm something of a magician prepare to
be amazed a
t inventor may I present Willy Walker's
wild and wonderful wishy-washy WKA
Walker please don't make me say that
again and chocolate
Baker the best chocolate of the
world
ooh he's good to good and anyone can
afford them even the the poor he doesn't
like it when people say poor send Wonka
a message do not sell chocolate in this
town you're going to get more than a
bonk on the head I of the manga man what
is with me
today you should stand up to those
Buddhist give them the old one
too I got an idea where do we start
making chocolate of
course
run away every good thing in this world
started with a
dream so you hold on to
yours I guess it's time to change the
[Music]
world
good night sir I am going
flat
huh what is it nothing well it's
obviously something because you said huh
forget it very
well
huh you did it again tell me what it is
or I shall poke you quite viciously with
a cocktail
[Music]
stick